I rarely Break characters the animal  like on set because Karen was the only  human and he's so contained because the  vampires get to be over the top great  character of like you know almost like a  farce you know and that's improvised  constantly all the time like our show is  made of 50 scripted and 50 YouTube yeah  yours is 50 improvised that's why this  cast I've never been with the cast like  this where everyone's firing on all  cylinders it's playing like hot potato  and the potatoes never dropped we had us  we had a season one take that ended up  being about 20 seconds in the show but  we shot for maybe 28 minutes of improv  just let the camera roll